[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast are you garbage
I'm your host stage Foley sitting to my
immediate left is the [ __ ] brains
behind the operation
he's the Tony Mann toiya of the
podcasting world he put this whole thing
together
my number one lazy gentleman can hate
you a little bit of business Kevin Ryan
everybody excited and offended by that
intro happy to be here everybody real
quick thanks for tuning in thanks
everybody that left reviews and shared
and everything like that we really
appreciate it thank you
awesome we are gonna get to the the game
in a minute but first I want to
introduce our guest this week super
excited to have him here
ladies and gentlemen check this out
ready this guy is not only been on The
Late Show once but he's been in a twice
once with David let him and once what
Stephen Colbert he's been on Conan he's
been on Last Comic Standing
this guy's got a [ __ ] Comedy Central
half hour it's gotta be on the new
season the last og he's got a brand new
show on Sirius called celebrate and went
to the combine in the NFL last year
broke everything
holding the [ __ ] stick it I'm staying
with comedy ladies and gentlemen Sean
Donnelly yeah the big dogs in the bill
happy to be here fellas honey that is a
resume the only question is is he
garbage am i garbage and I say I've been
thinking about this all morning I say
myself like a long day for you I'm gonna
play a game we're gonna play your
situation where somebody turns out not
to be garbage yeah for sure I'm sure so
far on in this endeavor no we had my
cannon we had Nate Mackin I saw my ad in
garbage yeah but Nate grew up as garbage
no longer garbage exactly like you can
you can phase-out of garbage you can
turn to garbage okay but like I also I'm
not sure I would want to I want to know
what you think you if you think you are
because growing on paper you got a
couple
a couple of blemishes here's the Pompeii
this old-school Irish you're an old
squat we think we're Irish
this guys [ __ ] are I am a Long Island
long as a [ __ ] I mean I swear we got
one on the reader led one of us Long
Island what about your attempt to escape
I don't think I'm not I'm not garbage
anymore self garbage qualities but like
growing up I we were pretty trashy uh
garbage he's still still still I'm
sneezing my hand to wipe my hand on my
sweatpants go see that's more Irish to
our shanty Irish wait so let me ask you
this blue collar as well blue collar up
bringing a my dad was a jail guard at
Rikers Island does that that's I don't
know that's just that's [ __ ] bad I
never use moisturizer once in his life
never no not even no no way
I was that I've only used it maybe three
times and every time I felt like a lady
what is this a spa day you should put
lotion on now yeah that's that makes
sense I come from a place where it'd be
like weird to use lotion and weird to go
to therapy to show now I do both yeah
can escape you try to escape I do I get
yeah well I don't know like I have a lot
of family members and a lot of people
like rubble to just lean the [ __ ] into
it and they're like this is what I am
like you know you know what I mean I'm
joining the [ __ ] Union I'm getting a
shore house you know yeah that's yeah I
was I was just an inch away from being
that dude I was I was that dude and then
I kinda you once you find how far I
guess you can't if you if you escape
your background totally I think you're
kind of a piece of [ __ ] do you know
named yeah of course if you cut if you
cut it off completely or people like
whatever are you talking about
gets rid of whatever accent they have
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so I think I
feel like that can you shaking
everything from your past you don't know
I don't think I shook everything I think
unless you have like a side of an
interview but unless you have like a
sleepers background you know what I mean
something like that yeah you really have
you ever killed a guy with a hotdog cart
yeah you can [ __ ] you can shoot for
the stars there Julia Roberts Julia
Roberts from slavery the enemy had a
reason to [ __ ] just a flick from the
town Robin baby I was reminded of
speaking of accents but we were in
Philly Philly has you know is known for
their [ __ ] Billy Long Island you know
it's all the same yeah we talked about
that though what do you think the
trashiest Boston's tough but I also see
it's always like the Al Staten Island
right with garbage is that an island
stuff that was born there the acts but I
mean that's like Manhattan
oh you Manhattanites don't have the
accent no I know what I mean it's louder
like but same with Philly like if you
grew up in Center City you don't really
have that thick it's like Northeast I'll
go you know it's like this around it's
always like the you know the more
impoverished surrounding areas yeah and
that's why Island to the farther you go
out on Long Island the more you know cuz
I got another world out there hey dude I
was out there once and this actually
makes no sense I was a burger king and
like he's too talkative or like whatever
it was called like a way out that's a
social issue [ __ ] music yeah you
aren't at the Plaza that was the girl
behind the counter Hyde Lee what sounded
like a southern act like it was that
it's this it gets that big I guess
that's it I used to I used to have a
really bad it's gotten way better since
I've moved up here and I just please do
what he's doing later he's going down
there you know like overall Street Road
two-for-one you call it's all night long
my six-year-old niece my six-year-old
niece will say some people used to come
up to me and go what part of the south
are you from I used to work yeah well I
worked at Mayo saying the N word about
people who like what part where are you
from I'm like Philadelphia they're like
no originally I'm like no Philadelphia
and they're like Oh
from the south like a weird drawl - it
does have a rear drawl - but this one
time we were walking down the street and
Philly we're down there doing shows and
remember with the little girls shoes
doing shoes yeah doing shoes when I go
back dropping your arse going I mean
hanging your ace so we were down there
the girls talked she was walking in
front of she goes hey mom remember when
we oh mom it was yo mom member when we
went to the aquarium and salt a hippo
poop in the water and I was like what
you need to be the mayor of Philadelphia
[Laughter]
see Long Island if you have it it's how
you say where you're from so like for me
like where are you from along what I
mean just saying Long Island he says one
word well few people say Philadelphia -
Philadelphia Eagles oh do they reality
it's all mumble together yeah yes
giggles I'm from Nassau County I'm from
buy life I found this out last night
Nassau County is the nice one right
there's now he was talking about this
the other night with somebody there's
Nassau and Suffolk yeah but Suffolk to
put this way Suffolk is so bad the
Hamptons wants to break free do
something like it's Quebec their own
County because of how Shh they should I
mean they probably put all the money
into it there Suffolk cops are like the
second highest paid cops in the country
does it a Hampton who's the Hamptons
yeah Wow it's pretty crazy so if you're
like in the Hamptons
you're like either somebody's from
somewhere else in your and your family
owns a house a short short but if you're
from Suffolk you are your tribe your
your yeah there's nice area of course
yeah but like you know most the time
it's like it's a thing man and it's also
like when I go out into the clubs out
there I'm like this is part of me like
sure know it well Seinfeld said no
matter how big you he's like it's you're
it's every party is yourself you hate
looking right back at yes not attractive
people no yeah but I but I also like I
find I embrace it a little bit because I
wasn't the brokerage once upon the first
times I like like close they're like
headline there and I I was talking with
girls after it I was like I'm so if you
guys you go to the road sometimes and
there's just like a trashy bartender I'm
like you're everything I thought I could
ever get
you are like but you as of now you've
gotten better like I'm like that's the
top of the tank
when you're if you're just like a roofer
up on Long Island you want to take her
out of there you want to give everyone a
vision or Bruce Springsteen song
you're like if I could get her if I
could get Jamie down Abby Anthony behind
the bar at the pub oh my if you get a
hot bartender over small town oh I had a
hardcore crush on the back of my
neighbourhood of course and she's
gorgeous and she's so cool and I like
for years my early 20s I was like I'm in
love with you I'm like in my head I'm
like oh my god I want to marry this
bartender do we always use we used to go
to the the pub it was the pub you know
in our hometown I feel like we got out
of college and stuff I'm like where the
locals go yeah and every like year there
would be like a new [ __ ] you know
smoke show small town girl in there you
know [ __ ] slinging your Bud Light
sold all night long and every time I
make a tight referee's you know hey how
you doing sweetie just a smoke show and
probably got a kid the whole got a town
house a couple towns over everything's
got a green light
but everybody be like you know who's
hooking up with you I heard Johnny
hooked up with Tina you know what I mean
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] Johnny got
those girls love the [ __ ] they
they're never life you think yes they do
yeah yeah you're the guys sitting there
at the bar being all sweet falling in
love with your them you're the mark yeah
you're gonna see her [ __ ] blowing
somebody know what you are are you at
the strip club without the screw without
the lap dances yeah see what I'm saying
sorry to interrupt you but you know I'm
saying like you're the dude it's
basically the strip club dynamic without
you actually getting laughed at yes
because you're there I knew guys like
that we used to go to this place croc
sleaze that's garbage
croc slattern I've never been there what
was most I can smell it's a like a
garbage man it was supposed to be fancy
like it was one of those bars try and
there's bars men to her that haul like a
hundred taps oh yeah like we go to the
fancy bar yeah yeah I'm gonna go lager
tonight so we go there and there was
dudes I was never
with a girl that I like that I was never
I would go there with my friends but
there was guys that would just come to
hang out with the girls local like the
barfly I almost thought they were in
like they were in I'm and I want to go
yeah yeah that's that happens there
definitely and that's why the only
difference between that and a stripper
is I shouldn't say that
but I know I know you I mean for the in
that guy's head he's going for the
affection and she's like oh I'm gonna
you know how's work Tommy or whatever
and she plays along with it get the cage
they break those girls off you know
pretty pretty hefty those guys that are
try at least I used to
yeah right exactly yeah yeah you think
you're like she's never gotten ten
before I had a good week don't worry
about always asking her about her kid
has Timmy doing now let me ask you this
do you go back and go to last or that
bar yeah we will we will guys and you
say it's like kids I grew up with
they're still in there you know what I
mean and every time you're in your
overcoat I'm like the limo so the car
around it is where I came from Johnny
Carson pardon me
I got out and I never looked back but
I'll still go back yeah from time to
time like if my friends were in town oh
my god let's go there grab you know
drinks or whatever over there and see
you'll see a lot of different people but
then you'll see some of the same crew
like the guy who went to jail yeah I
know one shout out the Vinny it's also a
thing where i'm like i well i did when i
was like 22 wow you probably guessed
whether the same thing like you tried
tried to leave as quickly as possible i
tried yeah the older I get the more I'm
like the more I go back and I'm like oh
I wish I didn't leave like it's one of
those kind of thing it's the realest
algid for for sure I also think it's
like the kind of the simplicity of it
you know I mean work because I work
comedies like a hard thing you're
constantly it's feels like you got a gun
to your head all the time and I go back
and I see [ __ ] video just still
sitting there [ __ ] slugging a shot of
jmo and a Yingling and a smoking a
signal and if I was doing out for the
past ten years sign me up yeah
absolutely I mean nothing but screen
doors and time I get that too I didn't
ever think I never thought about that
that I was like running away I guess I
was like long island's lame
I'm moving to the city I'm moving to New
York City oh it's gonna be better but
then when you get to New York saying you
meet everybody from all over first off
you meet people that I like you like you
sure yeah yeah a lot of people that like
don't being from around here like I mean
all the East Coast the Northeast type of
person too because of course when you go
on the road for comedy I'm like some
people are just like ah you talk too
fast I don't know I might as well been
from or you know what the [ __ ] is your
problem I go that guy gets it that guy
gets it like I can sit there I can talk
to him yes he gets it yeah it's easy
like there's no like what the [ __ ] is
this guy talking I'm just a regular guy
you know the guy's not like you know put
off therapy for a you know a lot of
emotional drinking issues so an Irish
Catholic Irish Catholic guy with a
drinking problem
exactly it's really what you're pegging
us for the three of us sit around here
come on this guy's pretty cool feelings
once it's it's just I I think the older
I get the more that that makes me more
like ah like would I move back too long
I actually thought of that my mom's
getting older I'm like would I move back
there and would it be a ditch anchors
now we've talked about it with you yeah
this is the change of pace we'll be
going back because I'm so used to being
in Brooklyn and Manhattan and I realized
it's changed me for the better I think I
do believe that for sure you let yeah of
course it opens up your eyes a little
bit absolutely more experiences you
don't realize how like narrow your
thinking was before you have no clue no
go back like oh and then now I'm like
but now like well do I want to go back
because I it's comfortable
do you not any mean but I'm not going to
bleh I understand what you mean yeah
yeah it's like yeah it's like an early
retirement a little bit like I can check
out a little I can check out 25% yeah
and just cruise a little bit if you
could still maintain a solid curl if you
get you in your headline if you get to a
headliner status I don't see anything
wrong you can make your day I mean well
yeah you can pick your days in the city
I'm coming in I'm gonna do - you know I
mean here Tuesday Wednesday Thursday or
whatever yeah
line up what you can get your work done
and get the [ __ ] out of there cuz I
still have this mindset of like if you
know I have to be doing spots every
night of the shore that but then what
kind of changes when it becomes the
headliner job whatever it is it's like
well you don't have you can mix it up
you don't have to be just doing like
random board shows and whatever close
sure yeah yeah so they can choose a
little more but I'm like if I fall off
for four days like I scrubbed on a lot
of comics and eggs I think even I read
half look I think it's even it's even
deeper it's like more ingrained in us
because it's a guilt thing it's like
dude the guilt gets you a terrible idea
yeah that's like guilt and then it's
also like that blue-collar mentality
it's like I don't think my dad ever took
a vacation ever it's like yeah I've been
working if you're not working he would
like be like hey I'm [ __ ] Johnny's on
vacation you [ __ ] believe that guy I'm
like oh okay yeah I can [ __ ] makasian
otherwise I'm a [ __ ] anyone like to
vacation yeah Florida and like Hershey
Pennsylvania that's pretty funny that's
almost that's a question on the game I
have that's a question I have on the
game it's a little different we I mean
there's no beach there's no but I'm
saying our perspectives in the music oh
I'm saying our perspective of a big
chocolate fans love there's love their
sauce baby Sarah I've stayed at Hotel
bragging rockefeller over here a couple
of weeks ago went for the big convention
and I wanted to say about their shitty
bars though the one thing that they do
always have that's amazing I got a
[ __ ] nice fried sampler yeah their
menus are do a chicken finger basket
from from a regional pub forget about
the marinara sauce they have with those
mozzarella sticks in those places I
don't know it must been cooking for
years they don't adjust how to fry
everything yeah there's some miserable
ex-cons your whole fat guy comes out
he's sweating he's wiping his hands
complaining about the boss yeah [ __ ]
Charlie's got me working a double
against [ __ ] [ __ ] he's done that okay
any more he's fried those for that fruit
a thousand pop oh yeah did you work in
kitchens growing up no I didn't ever
yeah no I did not
and I I kinda regret that I don't think
I'd be able to have been a server I
would have lost my mind the way I used
to love a well you got a short fuse and
you take disrespect you're a dude
he's like folks if you don't know this
kid's got an itchy trigger this guy
looking for a reason doesn't hide it
well his face look out sometimes
somebody like bump will be at a bar
someone somebody a bump in noma and I
was like I'm just making this up like I
said example summer like just casually
like it is all but something goes like
oh I'm sorry tsukino proud no it's fine
it's fine it's fine I get mad at you're
good I don't like you're good Oh after
when I go so I'll say sorry a couple of
times when I'm feeling myself I'll go
I'll go
yeah no I'm good I just said sorry
mm-hmm that's what it is he's got like
he's got to get that inch he's got a
scratch anything get that laughing I
know I know I'm good I know I'm good
why'd you say that of course I didn't I
didn't say I'm not good I just said
[Laughter]
before like it didn't mean that bite a
little kid take it easy
I thought you said you were okay no
you're good sure I get mad at myself if
I bump into somebody or if somebody
bumps into me
I instantly go I'm sorry instead of
saying excuse me I get you ahead of
myself why not cuz I think I see why am
i apologizing when we both bumped into
each other by I know and if they don't
say anything yesterday I almost I swear
to God I almost [ __ ] beat up these
two teenagers I was not gonna be the
conclusion of that story but continue
there's no way you're beating up to
anything
I almost got beat up by 2k
I better okay well I would get killed by
teenagers oh yeah but still you go down
swinging don't think of testicle or an
eyeball I went to the juice place and
this kid [ __ ] got Apple this kid gets
his juice and he drops it as soon as he
gets it like you know teenager like you
don't kid all over the floor gets all
over the floor
he doesn't really he's like ah [ __ ] man
he's like ma he says my bad to the guy I
got it all over my leg he doesn't
[ __ ] say anything to me he doesn't
say y'all I'm sorry man excuse me
nothing like yeah yeah so I was a woman
I'm like I'm one kid as I'm walking out
loudly I'm like this [ __ ] [ __ ] and
didn't he didn't follow me out or
anything I was ready to go I want your
[ __ ] head together I don't think so
now kids out in Queens they're [ __ ]
soft they're all skinny and soft you
don't realize how you don't realize how
aggressive we are as full-grown males
you don't know what vibe you're giving
offshore aciton I don't view myself I
mean it's a common trope anyway mice a
normal guy I mean I huge [ __ ] Kevin I
don't view myself as an adult that's I
have to do that sometimes be like oh I
am a man I'm a man yes
getting married cuz when I have to when
I see my wife now I'm like that's [ __ ]
that's weird I can't stranger I don't
like Russell wasn't on stage for they
Gail my wife and I'm like and then I'm
having this like breakdown on stage in
my head I'm like yeah I'd do that ones
to where I just there was a whole group
of teenagers and I just they were I was
walking they were in my they were like
going the wrong they were on the wrong
side and I just wore them yeah everybody
in your hey they're on the wrong side so
you're going I got to make this right a
little bit
absolutely yeah yeah they're on the
wrong side and I turn around they're
screaming at me to come back I just
waves in killing no freak that do you
ever see like it like a like a dad go
after a kid
oh yes [ __ ] frightening matter how
big the kid is the kids always [ __ ]
taking off guard cause it's [ __ ] some
forty five-year-old psycho saw my dad go
after a couple of kids couple a couple
of teenagers yeah [ __ ] full-blown
crazy person I remember he goes you want
to be a [ __ ] tomorrow my neighbor
like beat up my brother so I was like 5
years old
or something maybe my brother was like
12 or something this kid was like 16 or
17 like hurt like yeah he like crazy he
was right I know but to do it in like
the middle of the street like you want
to be [ __ ] tough I'll be WN you
fought like scream until had the whole
family oh yeah my dad was like they were
the family was [ __ ] themselves like
he was in there he was walking and I
remember you like my mother's go get
inside Kevin get inside I'm like oh God
and it was it was very trout which we
are [ __ ] full-blown Garbett it was
very uh it was very good fella's when he
when she goes go inside yeah he goes
across the street shot my Mailand okay
so my mom said Kevin go inside my dad's
just walking through the front yard and
Michael a ting good I know what he's
doing I'm old enough to know he's gonna
[ __ ] somebody up so the thing is my dad
was a really funny friendly guy but he
was super intimidating he almost got
I've seen pictures yeah he's like he's
like a more intimidating you yeah
exactly yeah and he used to watch him
get into fights but really they never
get into an actual foul but like anybody
would like one time right he would go no
TV trash trash all right all right
layer the onion the Donna Leone buck
Sonny not being garbage what he don't me
OTB that's some dermatologist Center or
something like but he wasn't but anyway
I always try to qualify he wouldn't
spend like our mortgage he would spend
like sure whatever was but anyway it was
right next like where the Mafia spot was
like the thus a strategically place it
was right next door to the soccer club
that was like all these like either one
of you mafia guys you're like yeah or
like actually connected guys so one day
he's at the OTB I went to go pick him up
as I had his car and I I was using it
what did he drive a 91 Buick LeSabre
[Music]
I had it after he was done with it it
was it was a fantastic car punched the
wheel and you make a right
whippin work shown on the high school
sorry just doing doughnuts in the
parking lot
those cars they're fantastic the big
engines and I had a key to Rio after it
and I felt like one of my balls was
gonna use to the big for the big boat
the Kia Rio if you could if you had was
that the SUV if you're the AC on and the
radio it would go slow the car would go
a little want a little one yeah it's
such a piece of [ __ ] car anyway
so he's at OTB my dad goes to make a bet
I walk in while he's walking back to his
spot and some like mafia dude liked or
whatever took his spot and he goes
you're in my spot they're in my chair my
spot and he goes 12 [ __ ] you
good night he goes what are you kidding
me are you serious and then he kind of
got it like my dad kind of got into it
with him and then the guys buddy was
sitting next to me goes kick his ass
Sonny and he goes it goes your name
Sonny you want to go see a movie once
and then he some guy behind us was I was
talking to his girl the girl he was with
for like and the guy was probably
there's like 40s that my dad was
probably like 50 something here and the
guy was talking throughout throughout
movies are a big deal for me because of
how me and my dad treated like sure like
you can't don't talk at the movie some
are you your [ __ ] [ __ ] and so all
through the the previews the guy was
talking and then all through the credits
and I could see my dad just boiling like
just waiting for this guy to be talking
during the action just waiting for the
first dialogue and yeah and then he goes
he just from his seat he looks back he
goes hey can you can you shut can you
shut up please shut the [ __ ] up mm-hmm
and then he goes you're the guy who shut
the [ __ ] up and he goes hey if I knew
you're gonna stand over here I talk I
will move my seat anyway the guy was
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you whatever was yeah
the guy my dad stands up he's acting
that big of a guy he's like five nine
yeah he stands up a hose I thought it
was like six nine no he's yeah no he
looks big right yeah uh stands up over
the guy and goes no [ __ ] you and the guy
slink grabs the girl and
it was great it was weird because if you
met him um he's a nice funny guy of
course I mean you got a cherry coke in
your hand and some milk what you see and
do you remember real innocent I don't
think it was probably it was some kind
of like but we used to go to like lethal
weapon to I show Patsy Ken's into boobs
when I was like 12 years old it was
exciting
he hated crowds well this is a kind of a
trashy thing so one time dad - my dad he
couldn't stand it and I was like 10
years old and I wanted to get Chuck
Taylor converse sweet when Monroe's will
feel more he walked in it must have been
like a holiday see of people just to see
if heads he looks at the thing he turns
right right he goes he takes 20 bucks he
throws that meal I meet you in the car I
mean Jen I was ten years old and I was
like well that's what's this thing I'm
afraid I'm afraid every that's social
anxiety ya know that right yeah my dad
same thing just does not a deal with it
yes it doesn't know what what to call it
yeah yeah I think I'm afraid of like I'm
afraid every social in my head every
every outcome of a situation could end
in a fight
oh you really think that yeah well
because the guy I'd like I've Jim I just
watch my dad like well this is what
we're gonna fight me now that was the
results well I think every guy is him
like that's the normal guys Molly I'm
expect all right if I say somebody if
like somebody cuts and running me line
if I say something I'm like oh I have to
be able to fight like I have to be ready
fight because yeah that's the insanity
that I was [ __ ] how many times them to
be in a fight I mean not any anymore
yeah yeah I mean yeah yeah the only
fights I ever gotten we're like I don't
even I saw my dad you know either of our
like traumatizing thing to see him in a
fight oh yeah did I see those videos
sometimes of like football fans getting
in fights
oh my god some bad some nagging like
that scarred for life that should've
been a [ __ ] what do you want work the
bag a little bit I mean a couple
training days my eye only finds I get
into
a drunk or drunk front so I don't get in
fights anymore yeah yeah it's crazy off
the sauce off the side are you well kind
of yeah pretty much that's a no but no
that's an Irish I'm still drink yeah I'm
still drinking here in there but I
haven't had beer and forever I don't
drink beer anymore what do you have when
you have a cocktail I'll have like I've
it's such a weird thing cells are in a
shot of whiskey separate that's a guy
trying to drown someone even I'm trying
to write a novel got a stark with a soda
back buddies in a tall boys we talk
about the the order in [ __ ] what's the
movie with Casey Affleck go already gone
you just did it yeah yeah when the dad
what not one you know do you ever see
going baby going I never saw it Oh super
depressing right it's like insanely guy
who's an alcoholic for a long time was
it was off the sauce and then something
happens in the movie where it's like
this is like [ __ ] it time he makes an
order he orders at the bar he goes three
cut he's in a tall boy and like you just
feel my god he's been ordering that in
his dreams for the past twenty years and
he look he doesn't even look at the bars
I just puts up his hand three Cudi's in
the tallboy you you feel the [ __ ]
alcoholic shiver in your bones that's
fantastic alright let's get into the
game here gang let's hop a little bit of
that are you garbage yeah right Shawn
we're gonna ask you a series of
questions okay this is excited whether
or not you are trash now as I said I
think you're not oh just up there's up
the top just a little buffer here some
things I bet he doesn't do you don't eat
in the subway no [ __ ] now you don't
buy food in the subway well you get a
chorizo every once in a while
no no
I think I went to a Burger King that was
in a subway Oh like in the kindig-it
near here it was on 34th in the subway
sure yeah yeah it's downstairs coming
nice it's not bad what's the password
triglyceride more arteries I'm a friend
of Crestor my name that's good but so no
but I will not buy food in the subway
now and I imagine your your mom ran a
tight household I imagine clean tight
when you were a kid my mom was a secret
hoarder three Cuddy's in a tallboy huh
we had the main part of the house was
[ __ ] and span right but I don't say [ __ ]
and span anymore right that's the thing
I don't think I don't know that run away
yes I'm not sure but I would say that if
you chromatic in our basement was was
filled with stuff it's so funny yeah I
know so many relatives that I think I
told er became hoarders on the low but
like not like that not like [ __ ] you
know the dead cats and chilly no no but
just like holding on to things that they
don't need to yeah I think it's an
emotional thing that a long time ago so
I think it's part it's party yeah
because it wasn't as bad when I was
young that makes sense hmm yeah never
had a liquid soap growing up I imagine
you were Irish Spring we were we were
dial we were dying dude that stuff used
it like two weeks ago when I was at my
parents house the hand soap hellobar it
smells great we're the white one Jurgen
no what was there was a white organ
there was a fancy night sir I wasn't
dove it was [ __ ] tough it was
probably wide enough dude after it looks
like a cinder block after got wet a
couple times the cracks in the floor I
was like I forget what it was but it was
not [ __ ]
we were like dial through I think I
think the whole time I was growing up
with style I don't think we did was
watching just ham washcloths one
washcloth with the family everybody had
their own I think it was like washcloths
when I was younger but then like it
became hand when I got older I got to
mighty name I know where were those
things
I still do bar so the flesh with anybody
[Laughter]
one of those those things are great
yellow ones the long man radio talk
about getting the day started one of
those high-class over there
what was the name of your uh what was
the name of what supermarket you guys go
to King :
that's big up here right it was going
sounds like there's a big drug dealer on
the corner King Collins place get a job
whenever the neighborhood needed money
what sounds like a Jewish superhero no
he was I think there might have been a
few of them but it was murder I've heard
the name before bunch cat always left
over from like the 50's yeah so I think
it still isn't that King Cole anymore
it might be a different name but it's
the place is still there yeah they oh
those companies always those people do
good that family in your town that had
the grocery store grocery store families
do well yes and then all of a sudden
[ __ ] twenty years I got twelve stores
they stoked to shop right for [ __ ] six
mill put a [ __ ] bang during high
school because she had a big nose and
now she's [ __ ] locked up
[Laughter]
she was Stephanie Lizzie just as I
remember all right go go I got here we
go
are you garbage Sean Donnelly our guest
stars I think that was a great talking
up front that was awesome oh cool was
fun times
um but question for you have you or any
member of your family ever been a member
of a studio audience I got it I got a
very similar yeah that's absolutely yeah
member of the Ricki Lake they give you
they give you sandwich I'm like a half
of Snickers in a warm coat it's not jail
your dad was there eat your fruit cup it
was like me and to be honest we kind of
went us half a goof but we still are man
yeah your family no not with me my
friends okay but but nobody said me
remember you said me remember your
family that wasn't that's not what they
did in ER she no no my rest of my family
I don't know I don't know maybe my
sisters were in the yeah my sister's
probably on some show but I don't know
what it was I got a I got AI got a
piggyback on that one that we anyone in
your family ever interview people on the
local news right behind it King Kullen
[Laughter]
robbery but here's the thing no but I
can tell you something yeah when I was
younger my dad's my dad's Buick was
stolen right it was stolen though TV
parking lot but then we [ __ ] trash by
the way my dad's Buick was stolen at the
Oh TV parking lot buddy if that's not
the trashiest sentence I ever heard I
don't know what the [ __ ] that's not
getting into Harvard
that comes up at the Senate confirmation
so two weeks later a cop shows up in her
house and he goes oh your car turned on
oh he goes your car was your Caprice
Classic station wagon the other car that
we had was stolen and used in a robbery
what and they go and buy my mom goes you
know it's the Buick and they go no and I
mom looks outside the Caprice is going
on do you believe in miracles
I asked his my I had a I had a cousin
when the Eagles were in the Super Bowl
right he went down to I guess the game
was in Miami or so he was in Florida so
he went down to Florida like party you
know it's probably in his early 20s or
whatever I mean I liked the sauce was a
big Boozer the next morning we're all
like watching the TV coverage leading up
or whatever and you know and they cut to
him they cut to my cousin on like the
local news he's got a big black eye what
happened to your faces like you should
see her he's not the sauce now doing
good but uh yeah it was but everybody
was just like wow [ __ ] that is rough
yeah so no did you're making a domestic
violence joke on the local news with a
black eye this guy knows no boundaries
on the news again
I know so we none of us were ever
interviewed on the local news yeah yeah
have you or any member of your family
ever gone to Jamaica and come back with
cornrows about spring break situation
with a couple of beads hanging yeah no
nobody nobody in my family you mean
right yeah yeah have you ever owned a
slip and slide yes so that's a poor
man's waterpark right there when we were
in East Meadow we had
nice meadow I'm pretty sure we had one I
like led to like a lawnmower you know
I'm saying like hey get along yeah you'd
hit something yeah there's a rocks under
and something jagged going we used to do
we had we had a slip'n side with no hill
but like so you would just finally kind
of stopped midway through your night so
we did stop halfway through so
anticlimactic also two of the sprinkler
we did play in the sprinkler that's
trash tied to the hose and just jump
through it jump back it was a slow one
right that would turn and go like it the
big hand come back white trash [ __ ]
holiday in the world you just wanted the
climate so you could get it on the way
back dimensions I was a good time that's
pretty trash that's like drinking from
the hose your drink right out of the
spigot look alright go fat so I got a
couple of questions sure let me ask you
something
when is the 3 liter of soda appropriate
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's an easy one at a family party
anytime you have income in an extent I
like communion the commute for the
communion party yeah or just big pizza
party or party had the big mouths on
them the big top you know the big the
bigger bigger gauge performance
appropriate whatever Doritos were
present Doritos and other good brands
ever did
three liters though yeah they did Pepsi
and Coke did they both did a every time
we hadn't was like Scott on them it was
RC Cola or just Cola just call it was
the bit was like the generic brands had
the big had the magnums as we call them
yes you know is generic when they had 99
cents on the ball oh yeah that place was
built in dealing with markets there was
no mortgage on that one it was
market markets oh that's great have you
ever that's Matt's my answer to that
yeah it was that's the right answer and
that's part yeah yes trash I mean unless
you say I don't know you're [ __ ] you
went to Harvard or something there's no
way you're bouncing your answer was
what's a 3-liter maybe oh my god have
you ever wanted no fear t-shirt now too
old for you were too old for tap out of
that I was to over tap out no fear was
big in the 90s yeah but I never wore it
okay I had one or two of them and I took
pride in wearing a baby have you ever
been stabbed by a parent or sibling with
anything pencil something like that
no but my friend had my friend his
sister tried to stand with a fork I
think she is this but but no no I've
never never got stabbed by anything no I
didn't have that's your sister so it's
harder yeah that's a little that's a
habit like I've had a brother probably
something well you didn't have a brother
no oh you and your brother would have
been [ __ ] me my brother did was fight
yeah we'd be destroying she's never
fought they were just like
psychologically [ __ ] me up yeah
classic classic girl you got a P they
make like ocean sounds like that kind of
do you have to give a Zippo lighter in
your family that would be considered a
family heirloom would it be in a will
anywhere cuz would it be bequeathed upon
somebody we got my dad Zippo from Nam oh
man it says I walked through the valley
of the shadow of death I fear no evil
for are the bat he was a Coolio fan no
way good looking broad that Coulee going
to baby have you seen grease to know so
I know not a lighter but a wallet dog
tags and my dad's bat my dad's a shield
from from being a crutch they're like
more like family stuff yeah
have you ever celebrated a birthday at
an Applebee's
[Music]
no no but no that was the go-to for us
we weren't but we would I don't think I
went to Applebee's as a kid how these
masks I think came later I was a teen
yeah we didn't Apple that was [ __ ] was
we would go we went we went for Berlin
to a place called the car stop we used
to go this might be worse
back in the day we're gonna make
Donald's my sister had a birthday party
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah the [ __ ] cake
with the sugar figures and yeah yes oh
you're the birthday McDonald's his
[ __ ] trap oh come on they used to do
and also know that is Harry he's going
right there with a little between my dad
being a cop and a correction officer he
had you odd jobs he was a bouncer at a
McDonald's on [ __ ] what the [ __ ] kind of
McDonald's has a bouncer ladies and
gentlemen do not attempt to adjust your
we have an exclusive here as any of you
were never family I've never ever been a
bouncer ladies and gentlemen this is a
first in Oh security where that didn't
where he didn't wear a security outfit
he played he plays by his own standards
over you can see LOX the play place now
use cable wait did you know when he
would work and would you be expecting
McDonald's when he came I think it was
when I was younger so I think I was too
little for that you would have been
hounding him oh my god definitely bother
but you didn't really bug him when he
came he work
well he would work that in the
afternoons I think when we wouldn't
bother him coming home from overnights
because you'd be like cranky stay away
stay a couple hours of sleep but in that
insane yeah he already guard quote
unquote but it but he didn't have a
[ __ ] even have the little stars yeah
he's just in his regular clothes at the
McDonald's they just undercover I think
they just hired him separately yeah yeah
McDonald's the guy who owned McDonald
exactly who owned the franchise was like
I need somebody just yeah hosted up in
here in case something happens it was
like they have a piece on uh Springfield
Boulevard right what do you have a piece
on him he might have that might have
been part I think he's walking it with
his [ __ ] thickness
if I get jammed up I want to be able to
I would have here one of y'all make some
action I got a couple of quick ones and
then I got one long one Kippy or three
questions Shawn have you ever been in
with sandals now have you or any member
of your family ever gone hunting with a
metal detector have you ever used metal
detector is there a metal detector in
your mother's garage right now now
there's not a own one I I what do you
mind I was gonna strike it big Kippy the
one bald man I think I'm I think I had I
went with my friend of the beach once in
Long Island and used his but it wasn't
mine so I was my mother would never go
that might be worse that's all I ever
wanted Dave yeah I never found certainly
wanted one I never matter what because I
don't think it's strong enough to find
out dude no no not at all I remember I
was like tested I like put it next to
like a piece like the car maybe and I
wouldn't register Kevin wants to be a
goonie down here can you skip this time
I was slow I wanted a strawberry
milkshake that's what he had when he saw
the Fratellis in the first crews buying
a really fast
yeah Jeff Cohen he's like everybody's
entertainment like super skinny that's
awesome
do you currently own any fireworks sure
m-80s Lena your moms out there anything
no but I was talking about my friends
that would be the day how my one friend
would just have fireworks yeah one time
my friend was trash yeah that elephant
sticks was like half a stick of dynamite
and he would put make time bombs out of
them by putting a cigarette next to it
and letting the second
you can call the ATF this guy's [ __ ]
honestly now it was now you'd be
arrested yeah yeah yeah God Kim um you
would mention your family's cars had
they ever had bumper stickers on them
yes definitely were they
I don't remember that's the only thing
that's not a good sign though nanni
bumper stickers never good no no I think
it was like to be honest it might have
been a used car though we bought it with
a came of the bumpers all I needed so
might have been like you know Nixon 70
whatever it is but I can't remember what
it was but you had them we definitely
had a car Pop's got a couple of t-shirts
that say if you can read this thank a
teacher if you can read this in English
thank you veteran if you own this your
garbage hikes have you or any member of
your family ever gone to like a State
Fair or a fair or something like that oh
they're just anything that was being
demonstrated at the fair live them yeah
oh yes yes we used to go to Jersey Shore
curly gutter or something like that no
it was like oh no you mean like a like a
product Oh a product no but we would get
like they would have like that like the
swirly art and we would get that oh yeah
yeah yeah
stand order like it was a piece of paper
with like the spray the wheel garbage
give me 15 bucks and go throw this out
in six months when I was real little for
some reason we went to this like State
Fair and we're expecting like you know
State Fair [ __ ] [ __ ] dude the
Pennsylvania State Fair at the racetrack
and Bensalem [ __ ] second to none I
got a got a corndog girl there I'm down
funnel cake and I would win knives I
would just guylove
I also did this I used to go we would we
would have fairs - but it was all tan it
was Italian stuff it's all through the
church we wouldn't have State Fair as we
have we would have yeah we would have
like they'd have rides and stuff and
then I go to Jersey Shore and they had
the Kingsburg boardwalk and Jersey Shore
which is like not great
but we would go and they had the giant
slide that giant yellow slide whatever
it was uh-huh but with the burlap carpet
yes yeah the potato sacks oh man that
thing I said fat kid crying [ __ ]
can't go down that was me yeah let me
win tickets and with my tickets one time
I got fart spray it was May 25th you
know it was it was I got my foreign
spray and snaps member snakes you like
the snake they grow oh yeah thanks for
big snaps I loved it go he's got a
friend that would just take the snap my
dad one time we went to like some kind
of State Fair and it was all
demonstrations I'm like we got like a
potato thing that likes rolling around
but it's classic my dad we go to this
one thing and this guy selling like some
kind of product for for the car like to
clean the car yeah it's like the ShamWow
guys they like the headset on just like
a real piece of [ __ ] yeah yes I'm a
dirty bag he's got a crowd of [ __ ]
young families in the early 80s crowded
around like like he's a [ __ ] miracle
worker my dad and my dad leans over our
mommy goes that's [ __ ] [ __ ] the
guy hears him all of a sudden out of
nowhere through this [ __ ] shitty
megaphone you hear what's that sir you
say it's [ __ ] we're gonna buy like
two cases of this [ __ ] [ __ ] sat in
our garage for [ __ ] 25 years that's
how good of a guy my dad my dad went
through a phase where he was ordering
item off the TV well no from the Lillian
Vernon girls I'm lady in your
neighborhood no and why and he would get
like little stuff like the pillow that
had a spot for the remote like that ah
by [ __ ] from this Webster everyone a
football so he was a catalog what
everyone a football phone her job her
phone now we had a Garfield phone Oh
Garfield phone
Garfield phone was big oh I had a Snoopy
phone I think was Snoopy my sister had a
Garfield phone bats and she loved it I
got one one more than we got to wrap it
up uh has anyone in your family ever
taking a couch or any other piece of
furniture out of the trash and taking it
home now what's the trash if you're
driving you see in neighborhoods they
have please take you can take it that's
trash I sure as if it's on the curb its
trash is literally a garbage question -
yes exactly um like a patio furniture a
couch for the garage was always big in
my name you're not talking about a yard
sale not I mean come on you're just a
[ __ ] trash what I'm selling your [ __ ]
to a bunch of their losers who can't
find a book afford to buy new [ __ ] your
trash I like a nice yard sale on a
Saturday morning
yeah we're time I agree but it's trash
find some old books I'll say this you
mad for cash not to my knowledge now
okay where you go we would go to go out
garage sales and yard sales oh yeah and
get stuff from there so my dad might've
grabbed some somewhere you like driving
out you see some you throw it in park
real quick you know yeah call up your
uncle with a pickup so yeah get a quick
I'm on time on Third Street maybe didn't
pull the trigger
I was definitely in the car with him
when he backed up to take a look it's
pretty trashy when you have things in
your front lawn that say like you know
you can have this for $200 or best offer
obeah or BR another driving thing real
quick it's not related but it's pretty
funny I was driving in the car in the
Buick with my dad once we're in Garden
City which is like the rich town where
well I went to school there but we grew
up in the town next door and we're
drugged the head of a gazebo where
people are taking like wedding photos
and so we drive by the with the fart
spray no you smell tu Delta
my dad might like to fade out on that
loses my dad slows down I think he's
gonna be like congratulations whatever
he slows down rolls on the window with
me in the car and goes chuckle and then
just keeps keeps driving and you would
have thought he was really crying
[ __ ] lost it was the best day of his
life
oh my god freaked out feeling great that
oh my god fantastic it was the funny
thing about Mike you know I'm not 40
right you know I don't know I don't get
married I'll have a girlfriend yet holy
[ __ ] gang what an episode Sean Donnelly
thank you so much for sitting with us
Kippy what kind of business we got I
just want a real quick give a shout-out
to the people who left us five star
reviews yes shut out the Beast big gay
aunt spuds McGillicuddy Kim sue baseball
freak else told Sully fail Bundy
FMS BK nor Oh Lenny penny scrubs JM f
slappy Oh Pappy court can't win and
gutter sloth Wow also if you have any
questions for the game your honest
answer you can email ru garbage at
gmail.com or hit us up on any you know
social media and play along at home if
you answered yes to any of the questions
that we asked Sean today your [ __ ]
trash and that's okay because we're all
trash and I'll tell you what I didn't
think Sean Donnelly was trash but he's
gone and we're all garbage and we say
I'm refuse yes yes he's bouncing back
trash we love you guys please hit the
subscribe button on YouTube ok subscribe
to us on iTunes if you have Android
Skippy where can they find Google Play
it's on anything a at Google Play I
Heart Radio everything please give us a
rate give us a review give us a
five-star and you know Kitty will read
your names in the podcast and we
appreciate you guys and keep supporting
us keep watching
are you garbage Sean Donnelly thank you
so much anything to plug away yeah my
the podcast called defend your movie and
a radio show unserious called celebrate
every Wednesday at 4:00 on night in
channel 99 perfect
check out Donnelly just check me out
Cameron comedy on all social media and
Kevin Ryan comedy calm very nice good
stuff congratulations on the show by the
way it's a new show yes
it's all very good stuff guys thank you
so much thanks we'll see you next week
see him oh thanks Shaunie no I think
it's hot in here